[Applaus]
[Musik]
eine kleine frage vorab erinnert ihr
euch noch an dieses nie heißt der
russische aussenminister sergej lasarew
anfang juni versuchte zu einem
staatsbesuch nach belgrad fliegen
verweigerten die nachbarländer serbiens
seinem flugzeug einfach ihren luftraum
zu durchfliegen
nato staaten blockieren das flugzeug des
russischen gesamten vor dem besuch in
serbien davos musste seinen besuch süden
absagen aber vielleicht ist dieses
detail der unwichtigste aspekt in der
ganzen geschichte wichtig ist vielmehr
eine andere frage warum um alles in der
welt sollte ein land wie serbien das
nemo libyen und der ukraine zu den
sieben offiziellen beitrittskandidaten
der europäischen union gehört den
russischen außenminister inmitten der
aktuellen politischen militärischen
situation und inmitten des russischen
einmarsches in der ukraine mit allen
ehren empfangen wollen diejenigen unter
euch die unser letztes video über
serbien und die geschichte jugoslawiens
gesehen haben wissen bereits buch von
ihr sprechen
[Musik]
denn im aktuellen kontext ist es nicht
immer einfach eine scharfe trennung
zwischen den zwei blöcken prowestlichen
und pro russischen ländern vorzunehmen
im fall des erwerbs werden die mit einer
anderen realität konfrontiert einem
dritten weg
stolz darauf nicht teil der
antirussischen hysterie zu sein
alexandra wohlleben serbische
innenminister
mit unseren 6 2 2022
es ist der günstigste preis in europa
wir werden einen dreijahresvertrag
unterzeichnen morgen oder übermorgen
über die gasmengen sprechen dass herr
braucht größere mengen aber wenn ich das
sagen davon werden einen sicheren winter
haben und weitere gespräche während
bestimmen wie viel uns das glas kosten
wird alexander muchitsch thermischer
präsident anbetracht all dessen könnte
man meinen dass die serbische position
einzig und allein vom geld bestimmt wird
nämlich sich in die arme des kreml zu
werfen um der eskalation der öl und
gaspreise zu entgehen die auf
internationaler ebene zu beobachten ist
aber obwohl es stimmt das geld immer
eine rolle spielt sind die dinge in
diesem fall nicht so einfach in diesem
video erzählen wir euch warum die größte
republik die aus dem zerfall des
ehemaligen jugoslawiens hervorgegangen
ist trotz des krieges in der ukraine und
kosmos wunsches der eu beizutreten auch
heute noch mit russland auskommen sind
also lasst uns gefangen
eine ziemlich unruhige geschichte in
bezug auf alles was der normalerweise
mit dem westen oder zumindest mit dem
atlantischen bündnis identifizieren
natürlich haben wir bereits viele
details zu diesem thema und über die
entstehung des heutigen serbien es in
unseren videos behandelt die ich euch in
der beschreibung verlinken werbe aber
für alle die sie noch nicht gesehen
haben hier eine kurze zusammenfassung
[Musik]
der höhepunkt oder besser gesagt der
tiefpunkt zellen den sowieso schon
schlechten beziehungen zwischen serbien
den vereinigten staaten und im übrigen
asiatischen verbündeten war 1999
erreicht als nato flugzeuge fast drei
monate lang militär und regierung
stellung in ganz serbien bombardierten
darunter auch die hauptstadt belgrad die
intervention der nato zielte darauf ab
die verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit
zum stoppen die im rahmen des konflikts
zwischen der ehemalige republik
jugoslawien und albanischen
unabhängigkeitskämpfern aus dem kosovo
begangen wurden konkret ging es um den
versuch einer sogenannten ethnischen
säuberungen das massenhafte vertreibung
und völkermord gegen die albanische
minderheit
[Musik]
und auch wenn sich die serbische politik
seither stark verändert hat hinterlassen
solche historischen ereignissen meist
ihren namen in diesem fall erklären sich
zum beispiel warum ein großer teil des
serbischen gesellschaft immer noch sehr
misstrauisch gegenüber der nato selbst
und generell gegenüber allem ist was mit
der westlichen gemeinschaft zu tun hat
und es erklärt auch die anhaltende
beliebtheit russlands bei den herren
schließlich hat sich moskau in den
internationalen institutionen stets auf
die jugoslawische bzw serbische seite
gestellt in einer gallup umfrage aus dem
jahr 2016 gaben zum beispiel mehr als 60
prozent der serben an dass sie die nato
immer noch als bedrohung wahrnehmen das
war eine der schlechtesten bewertungen
die das bündnis in allen mittel- und
osteuropäischen ländern erhielt in der
gleichen umfrage war das land mit der
besten meinung über die nato übrigens
kein geringeres als das kosovo
[Musik]
aber das ist noch nicht alles
ist auch das schlusslicht in europa will
ist und die unterstützung der
bevölkerung für seine mitgliedschaft in
der europäischen union geht im jahr 2019
sprach sich weniger als die hälfte des
herben dafür aus den eu beitreten und
rund 60 prozent vertrauten nicht den
europäischen institutionen und das
obwohl die selbe europäische union haben
in den letzten jahren mehr als 2,8
milliarden euro an entwicklungshilfe
überwiesen hat könnte dies also ein
gutes beispiel dafür sein wie die
europäischen institutionen ohne sinn und
verstand geldausgeben gut darüber
urteilen wir jetzt mal lieber nicht
belassen wir es vorerst bei dieser zahl
2,8 milliarden euro dabei sind einzelne
andere mitgliedsländer noch nicht mit
eingerechnet wenn damit würde sich der
betrag über den geräten praktisch
verdoppelt und falls ihr euch wundern
die europäische union ist der mit
abstand größte geldgeber dass herr bams
wenn jedoch die serben selbst ragt haben
natürlich nur drei von zehn diesen
eindruck der rest nun die meisten von
ihnen werden russland als den größten
wohltäter serbiens nennen und warum das
so ist werdet ihr am ende des videos
genau verstehen
das kurioseste von allem ist jedoch dass
es bei weitem nicht historische
streitigkeiten sind die den hauptgrund
für belgrad seiltanz zwischen brüssel
und moskau darstellen denn warum
eigentlich hat es ja den seine
integration in die europäische union
noch nicht abgeschlossen und warum
scheint es damit wenn gar nicht eilig zu
haben im gegensatz zu vielen anderen eu
aspiranten nun die antwort ist
supereinfach einen entscheidenden
stellen in serbien gibt es so gut wie
kein interesse an den von brüssel
geforderten obligatorischen auf formen
die das land für die eu fit machen
würden die herrschenden eliten setzen
darauf von dem staat israel aktuell
herrschenden verhältnissen möglichst
lange profitieren zu können während sie
parallel üblich beihilfen kassieren und
unter sich verteilen am liebsten würden
sie wollen dass serbien für immer quasi
ein schröder kandidat ist sie wollen
außerhalb aber gleichzeitig in gewisser
weise auch innerhalb der union seien
wasch mich aber mach mich nicht nass
erdogan lässt übrigens auch größen aber
ist das überhaupt dieses ganze tauziehen
mit der europäischen union notwendig
wenn die serbische gesellschaft den
westen suche sehr misstraut warum hält
sie dann überhaupt an ihrer kandidatur
für den weiteren zum club fest spielt da
vielleicht noch etwas anderes außer dem
schnöden mammon eine gewisse rolle und
was erklärt eigentlich die komplexen
beziehungen zwischen russland und
serbien nun all diese fragen über eines
der unbekanntesten länder in europa
werden wir im heutigen video beantworten
also aufgepasst
[Musik]
die klaviatur völkischer gefühle
ein umstand welcher der besonderen
positions- herr wiens besonders in die
hände spielt ist dass die idee des
kanzler wissen muss im sr wir noch gut
bekannt ist und sogar begrüßt wird dem
kanzler wissen muss könnt ihr euch als
eine annahme vorstellen dass nationen
deren bevölkerung gemeinsame wurzeln
haben hier zum beispiel die slawische
sprachen familie zusammenhalten sollten
aber auch wenn es im laufe der
geschichte zahlreiche vorschläge gab
dass die staaten mit slawischen erbe
zusammenschließen sollten verlor diese
idee im laufe des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts an bedeutung in den meisten
ländern in denen slawische sprachen
gesprochen werden wie zb polen und
tschechien und ist der kanzler wyss muss
schon vor vielen jahren in verruf
geraten als ideologisches trojanisches
pferd welches in wirklichkeit nur dazu
diente ihre koloniale unterwerfung durch
die hegemonialmacht russland für
rechtfertigen an da ist jedoch in
serbien wo viele diese acronis tisch
völkische idee immer noch nicht ein für
allemal begraben möchten und wenn es
eine sache gibt welche die russen zuerst
nach dem satz von jugoslawien und später
nach der gründung des herzens als
unabhängiger staat wir heute kennt
ausnutzen konnten dann ist es die
sogenannte slawische bruderschaft eine
bruderschaft welche die geschichte die
politik und sogar die religiöse
identität umfasst denn außer der
slawische sprache urteilen die serben
und russen ja auch das kyrillische
alphabet und vor allem den christlich
orthodoxen glauben und die religiöse
alias zwischen dem moskauer patriarchat
also der russisch orthodoxen kirche und
der serbischen kirche zählt natürlich
darauf ab sowohl innerhalb als auch
außerhalb dieser beiden länder einfluss
zu gewinnen ganz genau wieder einmal
wird religion als perfides
geopolitisches machtinstrument
missbraucht zum beispiel versuchen das
moskauer patriarchat und das serbische
patriarch ja seit jahren gemeinsam die
gesellschaft und die regierung von
montenegro zu beeinflussen einem land
das 2006 von serbien unabhängig wurde
momentan blicken ja wieder mal alle auf
das kosovo während die problematik
zwischen serbien und montenegro medial
vollkommen unterrepräsentiert ist keine
angst zum kosovo kommen wir auch noch
aber lasst uns doch zunächst einen etwas
genaueren blick auf montenegro werfen um
die gängige vernachlässigung ein wenig
zu kompensieren in montenegro einem land
das etwas prowestlicher ist alles
serbien bekennen sich mehr als 60
prozent der bevölkerung zur serbisch
orthodoxen kirche
und die serbisch orthodoxe kirche nutzt
in diesem land ihre große anhängerschaft
um sich aktiv am politischen leben des
landes zu beteiligen dies geschieht zum
beispiel indem sie politischen
kundgebungen und proteste organisiert an
denen sie aktiv teilnimmt oder sie
zumindest fördert dabei geht es um
andere auch gezielt und kampagnen gegen
die nato oder westliche institutionen
lebensweisen und werte
montenegrinische anti nato aktivisten
veranstalten neujahrsfeier ditto
russische opposition veranstaltet eine
anti nato party in der hauptstadt
podgorica mit dem segen der serbisch
orthodoxen kirche in montenegro aber
religion ist nur eines der mittel die
putins russland gefunden hat um die
serbische gesellschaft und den
einflussbereich dieses landes als hebel
in eigener sache zu nutzen den
bisherigen höhepunkt stellt der
putschversuch in montenegro im jahr 2016
da mit dem der ein jahr darauf erfolgte
beitritt des landes zur nato verhindert
werden sollte von einer das nicht
irgendwie an die ukraine nun am vorabend
der montenegrinische fußball 2016 gelang
es den sicherheitskräften des landes
eine gewaltsame regierungsumsturzes
vereinzelt die eine gruppe von
serbischen und in die klinischen und
russischen staatsbürgern geplant hatte
unter ihnen befand sich der ehemalige
chef des serbischen jean-marie branislav
micic und agenten der russischen
auslands und militär nachrichtendienste
natürlich sind seit diesem vorfall die
beziehungen zwischen podgorica und
sowohl belgrad als auch moskau nicht
mehr die besten und das heißt kein
billiges russen gas mehr für die
montenegriner dafür stationierte die
nato ihr erstes tiefe hybride
kriegsführung in montenegro und erst vor
zwei jahren 2020 beschuldigte der
montenegrinische präsident milo
djukanovic der serbischen präsidenten
alexander witsch und die belgrader
medien sich in die innenpolitik
montenegros einzumischen und die politik
eines großhändlers wiederbeleben zu
wollen
[Musik]
denn ein weiteres beispiel sind eben die
medien russland hat start in die
serbischen medien investiert sogar über
kostenlose publikationen im land medien
welche die lokale führung unterstützen
und im gegenzug moskaus eigene
politische agenda verbreiten diese
situation die sogar so weit dass man im
grunde genommen über ein und dieselbe
sache spricht wenn von serbischen und
russischen medien die rede ist ja so
geht gleichschaltung im internationalen
maßstab
belgrad verkündet offiziell dass der
eu-beitritt eine tolle zeit aber es hat
sich immer wieder gegen eine europäische
politik gewährt die den russischen
interessen zuwiderläuft während
regierungsnahe medien die scharfen
botschaften aus dem kreml wiederholen
aber wenn es ein thema gibt von denen
russland genau weiß dass es in der
serbischen gesellschaft immer noch
schwelt und das ist nutzen kann um
dieselben dem westlichen einfluss kann
zu halten dann ist es natürlich der
kosovo der kosovo wird von der
internationalen gesellschaft teilweise
als unabhängiger staat anerkannt aber
russland erkennt ihn nicht nur nicht
anfangen wenn es um dieses gebiet geht
stellt sich moskau internationalen
organisationen immer auf die seite
serviert
die europäische union hingegen will die
unabhängigkeit des kosovo anerkennen und
belgrad zum einlenken bewegen
tatsächlich ist eine der bedingungen für
den beitritt so dass belgrad eine
feindselige haltung gegenüber den
pfosten so aufgibt und einen prozess der
normalisierung der bilateralen
beziehungen einleiten doch das scheint
weder die regierung noch die serbische
gesellschaft selbst bereit zu sein
[Musik]
der kosovo erklärte vor 14 jahren seine
unabhängigkeit von serbien allerdings
leben unter den insgesamt 1,8 millionen
einwohnern rund 50.000 ethnische serben
und viele von ihnen kennen den kosovo
eben nicht als eigenständigen staat an
therapien verteilte dabei an dem kosovo
lebende serbische pässe und weigerte
sich standhaft kosovarische
ausweispapiere anzuerkennen erst
kürzlich in brand ein fester gott fliegt
weil es eher mit uns im kosovo ist
ablehnten vom kosovarischen staat
ausgestellte kfz nummernschilder an ihre
autos zu montieren und aus protest
errichteten sie straßensperren die von
der noch immer rund 3750 mann starken
nato friedenstruppe im kosovo entfernt
werden mussten aber der kosovo ist vor
allem ein thema für sich dass auch ein
eigenes video verdient hat vergisst also
bitte nicht das abo selbstständig mit
glöckchen und ist nicht zu verpassen
im heutigen video wollen wir uns eher
auf die rolle der eu konzentrieren und
natürlich auf die russlands denn
russland ist eben zum wichtigsten
unterstützer serbische nationalistischer
interessen internationalen institutionen
geworden ein freundschaftsdienst den es
sich natürlich durch entsprechendes
entgegenkommen beide durchsetzung seiner
eigenen agenda bezahlen lässt dabei gibt
es allerdings noch einen aspekt der euch
in serbien strategischer zwei
deutlichkeit überrascht konnte und zwar
nicht nur ein bisschen nämlich den
militärischen bereich fernsehen ist ein
land das weder der nato noch den
russischen gegenstück der organisation
des vertrags über kollektive sicherheit
ovks angehört aber es beteiligt sich
aktiv an beiden organisationen und zwar
zur gleichen zeit serbien ist ein
beobachter start des von ostern an
geführten bündnisses und gleichzeitig
mit die des nato programms partnerschaft
für den frieden und regelmäßig an
militärübungen beider organisationen
teil da ja immer viel über den begriff
der neutralität diskutiert wird schreibt
uns doch mal in den kommentarbereich ob
ihr dies als neutralität bezeichnet wird
oder er schon als zweispurigkeit aber
egal wie wir das ganze sehen und wir
mögen die rosinenpickerei im
wirtschaftlichen die im militärischen
bereich ist etwas das für belgrad
besonders wichtig ist
wir werden unsere politik gegenüber
russland nicht ändern wir bleiben im
brüderlichen beziehungen wir werden
unsere politik nicht ändern wir werden
weder der nato noch der vks beitreten
serbien hat seine eigene armee um sein
land und seinen himmel zu schützen
alexander muth straße des ruhms
diejenigen von euch die unsere
vorangegangenen videos über den balkan
gesehen haben wissen bereits dass die
serbische regierung ihren
militärhaushalt zwischen 2015 und 21
mehr als 70 prozent erhöht hat so dass
die worte des präsidenten nicht gerade
wie ein bluff klingen serbien ist stur
wenn es darum geht seine eigene
souveränität zu garantieren schließlich
geht es um ihre position ihrer wette auf
offenheit gegenüber beiden seiten und
diese wette scheint für sie ja nicht
gerade schlecht zu laufen aufgepasst
die serbischen brücke
die offizielle annahme der kandidatur
eines landes für den weiteren zur
europäischen union bringt erhebliche
vorteile mit sich sowohl in
wirtschaftlicher hinsicht als er heute
im blick auf die freizügigkeit der falls
herr dies stellt hier offensichtlich
keine ausnahme dar wir sprechen von
vorteilen wie visa freiheit bei reisen
direkten hilfspaketen und bevorzugten
zugang zum eu markt ohne zölle
regulierung und barrieren für viele
produkte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und achtung bereits 2030 hat serbien
dank des stabilisierungs und
assoziierungsabkommens mit der
europäischen union praktisch freien
zugang zum eu-markt dieses abkommen hat
dazu geführt dass die serbischen exporte
in die eu in die höhe geschnellt sind
und derzeit je nach jahr zwischen 58 und
68 prozent der gesamten auslaufen des
landes ausmachen darüber hinaus in die
länder des eu blogs auch die größten
investoren in der serbischen wirtschaft
seit 2010 in teilen auf die 60 bis 80
prozent aller ausländischen
direktinvestitionen die jedes jahr ins
land fließen
kurz gesagt wir haben es hier mit einer
immer weiter wachsenden verflechtung zu
tod die des serbischen wirtschaft sehr
gut getan hat der springende punkt ist
nun wenn man nicht die weiteren
hintergründe oder versteckten agenten
kennen würde müsste man angesichts
dieser daten natürlich glatt annehmen
dass man in belgrad verrückt danach sei
die integration in die europäische union
so schnell wie möglich abzuschließen
nicht wahr nun ist dieses jahr wir
wissen aber nicht der fall in den
jahresberichten mit denen brüssel über
die fortschritte bei den
wirtschaftlichen politischen und
rechtlichen reformen informiert die
serbien im hinblick auf seine
mitgliedschaft in der eu durchführen
müsste ist der ausdruck begrenzte
fortschritte derjenige der am häufigsten
zu finden ist und nun kommt der punkt
der serbien von den anderen
balkanländern unterscheidet die der eu
bereits beigetreten sind oder sich auf
den weg dorthin befinden wir sprechen
über die wirtschaftliche partnerschaft
mit russland und russlands verbündeten
japan unterhält nicht nur ein
stabilisierungs- und
assoziierungsabkommen mit der eu zwar
hat auch einen bevorzugten marktzugang
zur eurasischen wirtschaftsunion den von
moskau geführten wirtschaftsblock dem
russland weißrussland armenien
kasachstan und kirgisistan angehören wir
haben über diesen russischen
gegenentwurf zur eu bereits ein eigenes
video gedreht das ich euch verlinken
werde der markt der eurasischen
wirtschaftsunion es war viel viel
kleiner als der eu markt aber er hat
auch einen großen vorteil
es geht um einen bevorzugten zugang zum
energiesektor und zu rohstoffen und
nicht nur das ein weiterer wichtiger
vorteil für belgrad ist dass sich die
eine westliche unternehmen investoren
gerade deswegen für das land entschieden
haben weil es ja die ndr ein zugang zum
europäischen markt und zum markt
eurasischen union nutzen kann
denn auf diese weise fungiert das land
als eine art brücke zwischen den beiden
blöcken was der ansonsten kränkelnden
nationalen wirtschaft zugute kommt
westliche wie russische unternehmen wie
microsoft und coca cola siemens und fiat
haben erhebliche investitionen getätigt
um von der serbischen wirtschaftsverkehr
zwischen russland und russlands einfluss
tode zu profitieren ein weiterer grund
warum ist bisher wie ein sehr bequem war
sich mit moskau zu arrangieren und sich
nicht mit dem titel anzulegen ist seine
große abhängigkeit von russland im
energiesektor wenn die zahlen für
deutschland problematisch sind das sind
die für serbien regelrecht skandalös
im jahr 2020 machten die serbische
erdgas importe aus russland 64 prozent
gesamteinfuhren aus bei hohen öl und
flüssiggas sogar noch mehr wir reden
hier von mehr als 75 prozent der
serbischen energieimporte vor dieser
situation haben die vereinigten staaten
schon lange gewarnt
september 2016 usa dringen serbien und
slowenien energiequellen zu
diversifizieren
erschwerend kommt hinzu dass die
wichtigste serbische ölgesellschaft eni
es von der russischen gazprom neft
kontrolliert wird die über 56 prozent
der aktien besitzt wenn die russin
überhaupt etwas unternommen haben dann
nur den serbischen energiesektor weiter
sollen sich abhängig zu machen aber das
wird sicher nicht überraschen insgesamt
ist russland wenn auch weiterhin der
europäischen union der zweitgrößte
investor im land kurz gesagt belgrad hat
ist nicht eigentlich alle von brüssel
geforderten reformen durchzuführen um
ein vollwertiges mitglied der eu zu
werden schließlich genießt es bereits
viele der vorteile des gemeinsamen
marktes und eine eu-vollmitgliedschaft
würde das ende der geopolitischen
position bedeutend an der welt wachstum
interessiert ist natürlich konnten es
die internationalen sanktionen gegen
russland und die auswirkungen die sie
auf die russische wirtschaft haben
werden diese pläne völlig verändern die
waagschale endgültig kippen lassen und
serbien dazu bringen sich ein für
allemal für den eu-beitritt zu
entscheiden
[Musik]
allerdings hatte gegensatz zum kosovo
und montenegro die serbische regierung
wieder die russische invasion gegen die
ukrainischer verurteilt noch
unterstützte die sanktionen gegen das
syrische regime und sie weiß die
mehrheit der gesellschaft hinter sich
mit einer ganz eindeutige tendenz
während noch 2014 rund 58 prozent für
den eu-beitritt waren ist die
begeisterung für die eu so stark
zurückgegangen das jetzt 44 prozent der
serben dagegen und nur 35 prozent dafür
sind schließlich darf man aber selbst im
falle eines regierung oder
stimmungswechsel ist ja wir nicht
vergessen dass die tiefen kulturellen
historischen politischen und
wirtschaftlichen bindungen zwischen
serbien und russland dazu führen könnten
dass serbien zu einer art russischen
trojanischen pferd innerhalb der eu
werden könnte falls diese befürchtung
scheint auch in brüssel zu wachsen
weswegen man sich dort immer mehr die
frage stellt ob man dies hätten für
ihren optimismus nicht doch einen preis
zahlen lassen sollte denn selbst wenn
eine rückabwicklung des
assoziierungsabkommens
handelsschranken und zölle belgrad
weiter in die armut treiben sollte
russland wird den dann erfolgt mit
absturz der serbischen wirtschaft nicht
kompensieren können und serbien würde
noch weiter in der wirtschaftlichen
bedeutungslosigkeit versinken es wäre
das perfekte exempel mit dem man vor
allem im vergleich zum aufstieg
kroatiens und sloweniens demonstrieren
würde welche folgen es haben kann sich
die falschen freunde zu suchen und
vielleicht werden ja dann wenn das süße
eu-geld sowohl in den taschen der eliten
als auch der normale serbischen bürger
zählt auch die umfragewerte für die eu
wieder nach oben gehen manchmal muss man
eben etwas verlieren um zu begreifen wie
wertvoll es eigentlich für einen war
aber jetzt seid ihr erst mal an der
reihe glaubt ihr dass herr wie in der
europäischen union irgendwann beitreten
wird was haltet ihr davon das bild
gerade trotz des russischen einmarsches
in der ukraine seine freundschaftliche
position gegenüber dem kreml beibehält
sollte brüssel die daumenschrauben
gegenüber belgrad anziehen wie immer
sind wir auf eure angeregte diskussion
schon hochgradig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses video ist das gebracht hat
und vielleicht auch etwas dabei gelernt
was ja gibt es das einleiten von
freunden und vergesslich das abo mit
glöckchen um kann ist unsere videos dazu
verpassen natürlich freuen wir uns auch
jederzeit über eine spende von euch mit
ihr uns helft dieses projekt
weiterzuführen den paypal link dazu
findet ihr in der beschreibung in der
video macht gut und bis bald
[Musik]